before moving as early pseudos wonder
what the public will think about it so
they have test screenings with a group
of regular people that they call the
focus group you've all been through it
it's not pleasant sometimes and they ask
them questions about how they feel about
the movie and oftentimes a handful of
folks will change the way that a film is
finished so this is not a new thing
starting back in 1939 MGM not only had
focus groups but Louie B Meyer had them
filmed so he could watch them so the
Academy this week as you saw they they
bought a pair of ruby slippers which Tom
shark is wearing tonight but we have
some very rare footage on one of the
very first focus groups from the classic
film The Wizard of Oz watch thank you
very much we're awfully glad you came to
see us today and so without any further
ado how'd you like the movie everybody I
was somewhat perplexed we meet these
affable farmhands at the beginning of
the movie and yet they disappear and I
think that they should have incorporated
those characters into the movie so that
we care about them at the end
I love the flying monkeys you know I
play sex with the Cab Calloway band and
we always have an argument as to whether
or not monkeys can fly and this proves
it if you can teach a monkey to fly you
can teach a monkey to talk and what does
a flying monkey gonna say when he can
talk well I didn't get the thing what
the kids oh you mean the munchkins all
those little kids I didn't get it those
those are actually not children those
are adults but there I found them
irritating and you hire all these
children and and little people when
there are plenty of capable full-sized
man out in the breadline stealth huh
very interesting and any other any other
opinions anybody would like to I didn't
like until I got to the flying monkeys
uh-huh
there's lots of ugly faces in this film
lots of elevator faces faces that look
like they were caught in an elevator
smooshed together
hatchet faces long chins I've never seen
so many unattractive people I would flip
the whole thing I've started to move in
color then go to black and white and
flip it I didn't particularly care for
the rainbow shop cut the rainbow side
okay I find some of the tombs very
catchy Oh dirty little monkeys fire oh
no rainbow why can't I I feel that way
too sometimes I there is a particular
character that you would rather not see
that's easy Dorothy and the Good Witch
is a cruel jokester she should have told
Dorothy hours ago that she could have
clicked her heels we'd all be home
sooner wouldn't we was one green or am i
nuts well thank you very much you've
been a terrific audience and if any of
you want to tell your friends we're
gonna be screening another movie next
week Gone with the Wind
I hope it has some monkeys in it thank
you thank you so much
[Applause]